we just are such lucky people that we
get to eat this food and celebrate these
restaurants and what a better way to
kick off
our week uh celebrating meat then with
barbecue red oh please thank you so much
there are so
many amazing barbecue places around the
u.s and we couldn't possibly feature
them all but we're going to try
to cover the three bases with three
different restaurants in three different
cities
but first we need our taste testing
partner in crime
ross matthews well hi there hi fella
barbecuity
[Applause]
um all right let's not forget the steaks
yeah that's a meat pun
um the steaks being uh the spot with the
most votes wins
our battle of the bites trophy
[Music]
[Applause]
isn't it wonderful ross are you a fan of
barbecue
i don't have a beef with it
no of course i love barbecue whenever
i'm in any of these states i have to get
the barbecue
it's the best of the best and they do it
so differently so this is going to be
quite the battle
and now joining us for this taste test
are three
of our vff's hello to adrian emily
and mayball hi guys
hi guys hi we're so excited to do this
with you
and of course our final vote in the
competition comes from our social
media fans we put up a twitter poll
asking everyone at home to vote for
their favorite
and we'll count that as one vote towards
who becomes the winner at the end of
this all right let's get started now we
each have three plates of ribs
with a signature side all right i'm so
excited our first
app is king's restaurant please take a
look
hello my name is joe hoggett and i am
the owner of
king's restaurant here in kensington
north carolina the business started off
in 1936 by a fellow named frank king
and he had a son named wilbur senior he
brought his two brothers into the
business
and hence we became king's brother's
barbecue
today we're going to talk about our baby
about pork ribs how tender they are
and we smoke them here in-house
applewood smoked
they're so tender they fall off the bone
before they even get into the smoker
we don't use any fancy rubs or anything
like that we just use a really good
homemade
eastern north carolina barbecue sauce
last year we sold
39 000 pounds of babybel pork ribs
our featured side that we've decided to
use is power green
it's a southern staple a family recipe
has been
in king's restaurant for almost 85 years
we get our collard greens from a local
farmer not 20 miles away
we cook over 3 000 pounds of collard
greens a week
we supply restaurants all over eastern
north carolina with our collard greens
so in this difficult time when travel is
restricted
let pigs fly right into your house and
land
on your taste buds
jokes we welcome that yes please um all
right everybody you ready
yeah let's eat all right let's go
the smoke really goes through like your
nasal passages it goes in your whole
old factories i don't think it'd be that
flavorful yeah mm-hmm
okay that's incredible all right adrian
you're a james beard
award-winning writer food writer
you've had your fair share of ribs from
over 200 places
i am so honored to ask you what do you
think of these
hey it's so good to be with you so yeah
i like this this is really delicate you
know tender
um i put some of the grilling sauce that
i got on there so that added some flavor
and then
i love collard greens so i'm glad they
threw this in the mix this is a very
soulful touch
so have you tried these yet the color
greens okay get in this
this is so good oh my gosh
what is going on in this it's perfect oh
god
wow done oh thank you so
much adrian okay we're moving on
um to our next contender um
charles vargo's rendezvous check this
out
hi drew i'm robert head pit master at
the rendezvous
and i'm anna one of the managers at the
rendezvous in the 40s ribs had been a
staple of backyard barbecues in memphis
neighborhoods but they weren't served on
menus
at that time ribs were actually
considered scrap made and they were
extremely cheap
and for this reason charlie thought he'd
try him out that's when he developed his
own style and what is now known as
memphis style ribs to this day we still
cook the ribs the same way he cooked
them back then
we cook our ribs in this their pit 16
inches over five to preserve the
tenderness though
we base them in a prickle juice but once
the ribs are done before we play them to
you
we baste them again with another basic
solution to give them to you before we
put the dry rub on them we also provide
sauce on the side just in case you like
them a little
a little saucy the seasoning on the ribs
you're about to eat is what we've been
told is the original dry rub
and what ultimately makes our ribs and
our side that you're going to taste is a
mustard vinegar-based slaw
it is our family's hundred-year-old
recipe people have enjoyed the
rendezvous restaurant for seven decades
we seat over 700 people
at a time 4 000 people on a busy night
we
catered air force one a few times the
rolling stones have played in our dining
room
and even elvis have eaten rendezvous we
hope you guys enjoy this little taste of
our memphis barbecue
wow that's history air force one elvis
and the rolling stones are you ready
guys
so ready this is so different than the
last one
ready oh wow
oh that'll wake you up
[Music]
okay you can certainly taste all the
spices in that dry rub even the
texture's different right
yeah and it really has like a nice crust
on it
emily it's your family tradition to have
a rib fest every year
what are your thoughts on these ribs
this spice it just completely
permeates the rib and the meat and it
just
tastes absolutely amazing it's not too
overwhelming
but it has just um just such a great
flavor to it i love it
have you guys gone to town on this slaw
yet i'm obsessed with this i haven't
stopped eating the ribs yet
let me move over i feel so get ready
oh i know i know what's really great is
um how crunchy the slot is
yeah really good emily
thank you so much for your um permeating
especially words
favorites my honor please now we've
already tried ribs from
king's restaurant in north carolina from
charles vergos from tennessee and now we
get to do
joe's kansas city barbecue from kansas
check this out
hey drew hey ross eric tada here with
joe's kansas city barbecue in kansas
city
joe's kansas city barbecue started in
the 90s with our owners jeff
and joyce staney were on the
championship barbecue circuit and they
absolutely fell in love with serving
championship barbecue here in kansas
city
joe's kc has been a staple here in
kansas city for almost 25 years
and almost just as famous as our
barbecue is where we serve our barbecue
in a gas station joe's has been
fortunate to serve our barbecue
to president obama and the staff on air
force one we have
two hometown customers and jason sedakis
and paul rudd
and the great chef anthony bourdain once
said that joe's kc barbecue
is one of the 13 places you must eat
before you die this year alone joe's kc
is going to sell and ship 172 000 slabs
of ribs
nationwide we think our ribs are unique
because of how we cook them
we cook them low and slow at 245 degrees
for four hours over missouri white oak
so
drew ross we are super excited to be
part of this day
we also included some of our
championship barbecue beans
got a little spice for your palate i
think you're gonna enjoy
okay everybody you ready let's eat
very different so different than the
other two
but like that really beautiful
kind of what you really think is like a
barbecue sauce
there's certainly layers in this one yum
you're absolutely right bros maple
you were born and raised in the south
and you consider yourself authority on
barbecue ribs will you please give us
your thoughts
well drew i have to tell you this grip
is
good it's tangy it's um
easy to get come off of the bone it's um
the meat is
really tender and the sauce the sauce is
so amazing
it's right on point through it's really
really good
i think you're absolutely right about
that sauce maybe
they're all very different
so different um okay well it's time to
vote this is gonna be really hard before
we do
we asked you all to vote on twitter
to say who your favorite rib joint was
from all these extraordinary places
and 61 of the vote was joe's
barbecue wow i can see why
so that's one vote for joe's kansas city
barbecue i love
that they're in like that shamrock gas
station that is so cool that makes you
feel like such a foodie
okay and now it's our turn all right one
at a time we're gonna reveal
our favorite um so kick us off adrienne
kansas city okay i really really trust
your palette okay
beautiful emily what is your vote joe's
was phenomenal i agree but i have to go
with kings
okay stunning smart mabel what is your
vote
here's the city of course kansas city
here i come
oh all right oh my gosh
that's three i know um for joe's
ross it's your turn okay listen i loved
each one of these i don't have a bone to
pick with anyone but
one of them has to win and i have to say
it was the tenderness
and the side dish of collard greens that
put
king's restaurant over the road for me
it was so good
[Applause]
i have to do kings too
i was really not expecting how
much flavor would come out of those ribs
and i can't stop eating those collard
greens you're absolutely right
and i love the sauce so oh my gosh it's
a tie
so guess what both of those restaurants
are each getting the truck
[Applause]
all of these restaurants can be found on
none other than
gold belly heaven on earth gold belly
that should be their motto
congrats to all three restaurants thank
you so much for honoring us by
participating in this
and i really want to thank our vff's
adrian
emily and mabel thank you so much for
hanging out with us today
[Music]